I found my dad's wedding ring at my
mom's and then I walked to the beach
where Kristin was with a bottle of
champagne at sunset and I pulled the
ring out of my pocket brought door no
now it's awkward
[Music]
I was ready just yes yeah you weren't
are you it just feels like a whole big
thing that I don't really understand
maybe do a doc something that's a
serious camera the best partnership to
me just always seems so clinical term
whereas marriage has such a resonance of
lodge
I want a lifetime partner that a note
books domestic partnership is the easy
way out there's just so that I can have
health interests as nothing to do with
this other concrete ages okay it does
what kept me in our relationship was
what's wrong with me that I can't love
this woman for exactly who she is I
think more and more this is becoming
about you her going to my dad's house
you got divorced was it hard for you to
leave
[Music]
finally an eternal this rest I know that
you've been looking for shoes and rider
I hear you don't understand little big
visit party I hope you feeling
I think the waters cold
yep do you want to walk in it anyway
[Music]
[Applause]
you
you